the same skytran technologies for linear
synchronous motors and the Maglev are
being applied to wind technologies what
we're doing with our partner one cycle
control and power conversion there's a
couple aspects of this we are number one
we're building a unit here in irvine to
go up in Palm Springs to replace a 1980s
Norwegian 58 foot diameter windmill 65
kilowatts this should be going up in a
couple of weeks as and we'll have to
test it for a couple months and then
there's going to be several hundred if
they like the data they see in other
words we do all this math and physics
but now you've got to build stuff and
prove it so that's what we're doing so
this technology we will eliminate the
gearboxes where you have a direct drive
system forty percent of a lifetime costs
of windmills is the gearboxes they wear
out the same reason on skytrain you
don't want gearboxes and tires things
where up the other aspect is the power
conversion we can take low low speeds
and high high speeds and supply to the
utility Southern California Edison in
this instance proper frequency electric
there was if all your frequency is 60
cycle maybe they can accept between 50
and 70 well if their grid is being
pulled down to say 59.3 cycles a second
guess what we're going to deliver 59.3
and this is the one cycle control power
technology what this enables is we can
gather energy at very low speeds and
higher speeds up to the limitations
where you have a good structural safety
factor on the props we side by side the
geared type system compared to our
system in a year we should be able to
sell about double the energy to Southern
California Edison on the same wind
profile on the same Hill this is going
to be pretty hot we're getting
out of interest and financial interest
in this technology and it really
actually gets better when we start
talking three or five megawatt wind
mills the big ones and there's even ten
megawatt wind mills up being designed
not to